whoa before we get started I want to go
over the four sponsors for this episode
who make all this possible
they're fantastic so go show them some
love the first is the best URL in the
industry crypto comm their crypto
platform with one goal driving mass
adoption that's why we're all here right
to get every human on earth a digital
wallet and to get them using digital
currencies crypto comms helping people
do that through buying earning lending
and a new card payment everything you
could want is at crypto calm they've
been longtime supporters of
off-the-chain and recently announced a
new exchange so go help them out
download their app from the App Store or
visit crypto comm and tell them pom sent
you there's nothing better in the world
than a company helping to drive global
adoption of this new technology another
part of global adoption is making sure
that we secure the various block chains
with computing power coin mine has built
the best consumer experience in mining
hands-down no competition if you want to
help secure the blockchain and get
started in mining you can go to coin
mine comm slash pop order a coin mine
it'll arrive at your door
and you simply take it out of the box
plug it in and connect to your Wi-Fi
you'll be mining your favorite crypto in
five minutes or less it is honestly
magical I have one running right now
here in the office and it's super quiet
it's got no heat and every person that
comes in the office asks what is that
every single person asks it's a coin
mine the best part to me is that the
coin mine comes with a mobile app that's
super slick and the company continues to
push over-the-air updates to the device
that add functionality ad tokens that
can be mine or increase the efficiency
of the device similar to how Tesla does
car software updates over the air
coin mines sending these passively to
thousands of coin mines around the world
on a periodic basis pretty damn cool
when far booed and the team pitched me
on the idea of an Xbox or Playstation
like box that could mine cryptocurrency
in your home I was immediately sold I
invested in the business have a device
personally and keep telling people to go
to coin mine comm / pump so they can
save a lot of time if they want to get
started mining today in coin mine has a
partnership with our third sponsor for
this episode block 5 block 5 is one of
my favorite companies in crypto because
they allow users to deposit their assets
in a deposit account and immediately
start earning interest think about it if
you keep your digital assets on an
exchange or in cold storage you aren't
benefiting from any yield on the
asset with block fie they allow you to
deposit crypto and then get paid
interest on a monthly basis in crypto
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in eath you can do it
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in Bitcoin you can do
it the rates have block fire are
currently some of the best in the
industry
you can earn six percent interest on
Bitcoin and you can earn up to eight
point six percent 8py on G USD deposits
I'm an investor in the company and think
block fights building really important
and compelling infrastructure so go
check them out at block fire comm slash
pump again this block five comm slash
pump and that brings us to the last
advertiser of the episode eToro these
guys have absolutely crushed it over the
years their founder yoni was one of the
original Bitcoin OGIS that has been
ahead of almost every trend in crypto he
built eToro to help people buy sell and
trade crypto currencies but he added a
few twists social trading copy trading
and virtual trading accounts social
trading is a feature where every asset
available on the platform has its own
separate social feed where people talk
about the asset share trading ideas and
analysis and even include various charts
or graphs virtual trading accounts is
targeted at beginners if you're just
starting out and want to try trading
with play money eToro will give you a
virtual account with $100,000 in it to
test learn and get comfortable and so
then that brings us to copy trading
which is by far the coolest feature this
allows you as a user to select any other
users portfolio to copy if you see
someone on the platform you like you can
set your account to mimic their trades
they buy Bitcoin with 5% of their
portfolio your portfolio buys 5% Bitcoin
they sell 50% of their ether position
your portfolio does the same thing
automatically copy trading is awesome so
go join the 10 plus million other
traders on eToro and start trading all
the most popular cryptocurrencies today
they're one of the largest companies in
the space and you can get started by
going to e Toro comm again that is eToro
comm where the entire team is ready to
get you started in just a few clicks and
don't forget go subscribe to the
off-the-chain daily newsletter you can
go to off-the-chain sub stack comm I
write a letter of news analysis and
opinion every morning that goes out to
more than 40000 investors see you there
what's up everyone this is anthony
papparella know most of you know me as
pomp you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Ryan Leslie
is an American recording artist and
record producer from Washington DC he's
produced singles for a number of
prominent artists in a variety of genres
ranging from R&B and hip-hop to pop and
gospel in 2011 he was nominated for a
Grammy
Ryan graduated from Harvard University
and has made a big push into
entrepreneurship in the last few years
where he's the founder and CEO of
superphone and next selection lifestyle
group in this conversation we discussed
graduated from Harvard what it is like
producing music with jay-z and Kanye how
ryan discovered entrepreneurship what
his big idea behind superphone is and
then ryan tells us a bunch of awesome
behind-the-scenes stories that you don't
want to miss I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
Anthony pomp Leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I got mr. Ryan
Leslie ere there's gonna be too much fun
so we're gonna try to to keep this clean
and try to keep it where we have not as
much fun as everyone at home so thank
you for coming on and doing this oh
we're gonna have a great time
all right let's get first of all let's
start with the music stuff I think most
people know you as a musician for all of
your music walk us through how do you
frankly just kill it in music for so
long yeah I moved to New York City on an
unpaid internship in 2003 and this is uh
five six years after I got out of
college told my well I went to Harvard
right of all places to have a starting
music Harvard University right I told my
dad I wanted to do music and man ended
up back on
couch in 2000 98 was on his couch in the
fall of 2002 and called a little
opportunity unpaid internship in New
York City 2003 and 30 days into my
internship landed a meeting with puffy
puffy became my manager he managed me
from 2003 to 2005 I learned really
everything I know about the music
business really from a reading a book
called all you need to know about the
music and then be actually having to of
probably the most polarizing and at the
same time most exciting executives and
just personalities in music business as
mentors and I was Sean Diddy Combs and
Tommy Mottola Mann and so that first
year are those first two years I worked
with everybody my first record was a was
a record for Beyonce on the bad boys to
movie soundtrack I'll keep giving your
love to me and then over those two years
just work with everybody Britney Spears
snoop and really that was directly
correlated to the fact that when you're
working in puppies camp you have access
to every project you can touch really
any project that's happening so that was
really the that was really my training
ground and then in 2005 I started to
realize that the internet was going to
drastically change the way music was
both discovered and distributed and a
partner of mine by the name of Rashid
Richmond introduced me to the myspace
music charts at the time and he didn't
just introduce me to the charts he also
came with a game plan and that game plan
was that he actually was like yo I can
control the myspace keyword and I said
well what does that even mean he said
well look myspace ISM bidding on their
own keyword cuz they're already the
number one organic Google search result
for the keyword MySpace but we can own 2
through 8 organic based on some SEO SEM
and so man I took my girlfriend at the
time we made a myspace profile for I
made a song for her and over the next
three months she went from zero to
650,000 friends based on this little how
Google algorithm had
and man that song was called me and you
and it went on to be top 10 in 8
different countries and my previous
mentor ended up signing Cassie and she
was the first artist to have a
one-to-one correlation between social
following in sales so 650,000 friends on
MySpace 650 650 thousand units sold
650,000 friends on MySpace
650,000 units sold and that's when I
really knew that that I had a real
passion for disruption and being able to
sort of turn the entire model for the
music business upside down was really
kind of that first foray for me into
just technology and the marriage of
technology and creativity and so I went
on a consult puffy on how to grow his
myspace profile and then puffy and
Cassie fell in love and I never made a
record with her again and man that was
that was that was that was a great time
because they say out of heartbreak is
born you know great inspiration for our
me I made two albums and man the second
one was grammy-nominated continued to
produce for a bunch of folks worked on
Kanye and jay-z's Watch the Throne did a
bunch of sessions with them you know I
just start with what was the job that
you were coming on paid internship what
were you supposed to be doing when you
first came yeah so what was happening is
that you know puffy had a team of
producers that was called the hit men
and puppies got a favorite line that
says take hits from the 80s and make it
sound so crazy the issue with taking
hits from the 80s making it sound so
crazy is that when the song blows up the
people that produced the record only get
a sliver of those earnings because the
original copyright owners whether it's
such a long affair exactly because they
own the copyrights right so the producer
that I was working with his name is
young Lord said look man you know can
you actually play original chord
progressions instead of me having a
sample them and I said yeah sure of
course I can and so that's what I did
that's what
that's what I came to New York to do he
had drum beats and drum loops and was
looking for dope chord progressions that
he could place on top of them so that
when a record hit yeah we could actually
legitimately split the earnings instead
of having to pay a third party and so
that's what I did that's it that's what
I that's what I came in again so uh
what's a puffy like oh he's amazing man
he's amazing the first thing you
remember about him men to be honest the
first thing I really remember about
puffy is that he had so much of a
presence and influence on Harvard's
campus and I had never even met Lee guy
you know and so in the president
influence that he had on Harvard's
campus was that you know just you know
an hour away in New York City was this
music that was moving all the parties
moving all the social events that was
the soundtrack really you know that bad
boy ever it was really the soundtrack to
my whole college career so meeting him
finally was really just like I really
felt like I already knew him and he
really was everything he had every
element that I expected him to have you
know an incredible tenacity and
incredible work ethic an incredible sort
of discernment for the kinds of people
that he wanted to have around him and
and a real love for music and a real
love for entrepreneurship and he really
exemplified I think what you know my
homie a ser Fergus is continuing to bear
the torch for and that is just like that
Harlem hustler mentality man and so when
I moved to New York out of when I when I
first came I was in young Lords cribs
and when I moved I wanted to move to
Harlem to that epicenter of what you
know that hustles that I have that I had
always admired and had had a chance to
actually work closely with in Puffy's
camp yeah there's a song what is it
enough bad boys for life I think with a
music video they're riding the bikes
down the street yeah I'm all right now
it's a hit yeah I remember listen that
over and over and over again
inspirational man so you know when you
see when you see everything that's been
happening before this
if you're unfamiliar go back and check
out those videos and then for more
modern day just look at what the ASAP
mob is doing a rocky ASAP ferg and you
know those kind of party starting
records you know dress and fly you know
nice and smooth with the ladies all of
that do you know that's that's
everything that you know camera like
music sets culture yes right and I think
a lot of people they're used to
listening to music a lot of times you
actually listen to stuff you don't even
realize what it is you just you've heard
the song before you've heard that you
know the beats whatever but music
definitely sets culture and I think now
what we're starting to see is musicians
that are realizing whether it's Kanye or
others saying look I'm not just a
musician I'm not this one-dimensional
person yeah I can actually go and do
other things yeah right and because I
think there's a lot of people who are
musicians who can do other things
there's not a lot of people who do other
things that can be musicians right that
creativity and that skill set is could
serve you really well when you break out
of just music that's the legs
absolutely absolutely what what uh what
what's the one artist that you worked
with that you got a great story for us
that people probably haven't heard
before men what's your favorite memory
working with all these artists listen I
would have to say working with Kanye and
hope on the wasa throne sessions was
Lenny their legendary life changing for
me just because I mean we started in
Bath England at Peter Gabriel's studio
and mind you that studio already just
looks like a spaceship so you can
imagine me pulling up and you know
playing some beats for Kanye and then
you know having communal lunches or
dinners would you know it's Hovis
Beyonce's Kai and this is all before the
lots of thrown albums so we just knew
that something incredible was brewing
and just to be part of that process was
incredible but I remember one night in
Australia because we ended up doing it
we did Bath England we did Paris with
the Mercer we did Sydney Australian so
there was this big mansion in Australia
I went out to check them and at the time
Oprah was broadcasting her show from I
think the Sydney Opera House and jay-z
was a guest on the show
you know I stay up really late I taught
myself sort of Dymaxion sleep when I was
in college just so I can add more hours
to the day and so one night it really
was just me jay-z an engineer in the
living room of this big mansion in
Australia and he said you know he looked
over at me and I don't drink but he's
you know having a drink I had some
ginger ale probably some men and he says
look you know who's gonna catch up to me
and I said what you mean I said look I
started my day you know I went out I did
the Oprah taping you know I spent some
time with with my lady on the boat I
went and did I open for you too and now
I'm at the studio and everyone else is
asleep except for you and I am already
where I am so who's gonna be able to
catch up to me
working man that was just such a
impactful moment for me because that's
the kind of work ethic to which I aspire
and you know I think there definitely is
in everyone's pathway to success there's
always a sprinkle of luck but I also
believe that you can reduce dependency
on luck by having a great work ethic and
having a great amount of that work ethic
being invested in building the right
relationships look I talked about all
time there's people who are good at
something and then there's the select
few that are great right whether it's a
basketball player in less efficient
right entrepreneur whatever right you
can be good by rolling out of bed yeah
right there's some people who just look
you got lucky one though very and
lottery right you just just six five and
you got a 44 inch vertical yeah you
should be able to dunk like that but
Kobe Bryant right is notorious for one
of my favorite stories is uh he was at a
pregame before the game Randy and he
goes out on the court and Jay Williams
the the famous a Duke star said that he
was out there shooting and Kobe came out
went down the other end and they're on
opposing teams so Jay starts shooting
and Kobe starts shooting and Jay was
like I'd already been out there for
about an hour so I did another thirty
minutes whatever not leave and and by
the time I leave Kobe Bryant you know
breaking a sweat nice suit and he's
shooting he's shooting and I walk inside
in the locker room go out
that game that night and Kobe [ __ ] you
know put up 40 points or something like
that too late good man cope how'd you do
that you know you spent an hour and a
half before the game doing this or
whatever and he goes man I want leaving
that court til you left just so you knew
you were in my house and it was just he
was playing a game before the game even
started right and he was out there he
was work and he was doing all stuff and
so it's that idea of you take somebody
who even men jay-z had a pretty big lead
on people in terms of what he was doing
and for him to say things like who's
gonna catch me yeah we shouldn't be
surprised at what he's doing now right
where he's gotten those because you you
know you you had a front-row seat to
some of that hard work and light and
kind of seen that path no surprise no
surprised and proud proud proud of it
man you know I feel like especially for
folks who really get it out the mud as
they say right so you really come from
nothing and when I say come from nothing
we're not even talking about starting
with nothing but we talk about
generationally prior to when you arrived
on the earth you maybe even had a
negative pretty cycle yeah you know what
I mean
so to see that and to see that kind of
success and to see that that that it can
be replicated is really I think one of
the greatest motivators for the work
that I do every day for sure what's
Kanye like oh man he's amazing as well I
mean one of my favorite things he says
is dub' a genius you know that's not
crazy Yeah right I agree I agree I agree
and I think also men just from a taste
level and just being a for what I've
observed just being around Kanye is just
a voracious appetite for knowledge and
also once he's formulated his
perspective and point of view he's very
very true to it as an artist and I think
that authenticity has served him
extremely well across all the different
platforms where he's been creative and I
think he's bred that in his camp so when
you look at what Virgil's been able to
do at Louis Vuitton and Nike and
everywhere else that he's actually been
able to touch creatively
that's all from I think being fostered
in that environment of just like
creativity artistic authenticity and I
think Kanye really was was a game
changer and continues to be a game
changer in that regard he
fascinated me because I was I was joking
at first and then people started sending
me articles that say it might be true
that Kanye is a billionaire right and
it's because he owns easy a my
understanding was a hundred percent of
it but he's got some kind of rev share
deal with adidas on it but on that the
dudes sold over a billion dollars worth
of gear yeah right yeah you could say
adidas helped them whatever yeah you
don't do that by accident yeah no it's
true it's right it's true it's true it's
true so yeah I mean listen to be in the
company of those greats to work
alongside to be respected as a peer to
be respected as a co-creator to be
respected as someone who was valuable in
the creative and business process is is
is an accolade that I don't take lightly
I take that with the with a great deal
of pride and responsibility you know I
mean yeah so we met a couple years ago
and and I told you they're not and I've
reminded you today that the very first
time I ever heard about you knew about
you anything was I saw a video on
YouTube of Frank some some mad man
sitting in an apartment right New York
and you had a cup of change little coins
and you were shaking it yeah that turned
into a part of a beat and then you went
over and you started playing on a
keyboard that turn and it was leather
you were making a song right um what's
the video called the video is called
Ryan Leslie I gets money gets money if
you want to take a look at it yes on
YouTube just do the search you'll find
it you're a grammy-nominated artist all
stuff and I know you because of this
viral YouTube video yes and I think
that's really just a testament to the
fact that you have to be an early mover
on social channels in order to actually
win in that arbitrage and so for me the
minute I discovered that YouTube was
available and it was free I was wearing
the first guys on that to go their
platforms you know to the point where
they knew who I was sending me t-shirts
and all kind of other you know merchant
gear and swag just because I was one of
those folks that not only was I using
the platform I was using that platform
in a way that was disruptive you know so
seeing the actual
the actual beat is being made I think
really really fathered a lot of folks
today who are doing that so that they
can get some exposure for what they're
doing for sure so you got a whole other
part of your life but before we get to
that I've always wondered somebody who's
got the musical talent that you have do
you just walk down the street with beats
in your head like are you sitting there
just sing a Ling Li like man I heard
that no you know I heard that bus door
closed that could be part of you know
this beat or whatever or is it more of
you've got to have a really concentrated
focus let me go into a studio and that's
where kind of all the magic happens
listen my dad told me a story that I
don't even recall he said when he was in
college he brought I was already around
when he was in college so he might my
mother were actually the Salvation Army
Training College okay and Atlanta
Georgia and he said that he gave me a
quarter or something to go get a soda so
mine just sewed it was only a quarter
back then and I didn't come back and so
he's wondering like okay what's going on
with Ryan like this the soda machine is
right in the hallway right down the hall
where'd he go he comes to the soda
machine and I'm like hey Dad the soda
machine is making a beat because it had
a rhythm to the whirring so I'm sitting
next to the machine just bobbing my head
instead of getting a soda I'm hearing
music and he said look you know this kid
is gonna have music in him and so just
crazy
to that end fast forward to today my
crew you know we ride around New York
and I think one of the one of the most
fascinating idiosyncrasies is that I
ride in silence other people listen to
the radio listen a podcast listen to
music I ride in silence and the reason I
ride in silence is that when I'm in
transit in that way I actually hear
music that's fully completed so I don't
just hear like like you said maybe a
door closing or back when I was a little
kid maybe I heard the Coke machine
whirring and I could hear a beat that
way now I actually hear fully formed
compositions and so my process in the
studio is really racing against my mind
to to actually bring to fruition the
fully formed compositions that I hear in
my head that that's crazy that you
basically you
come up with the music in your mind and
then the challenge is actually trying to
get it from your mind yeah to the audio
file yeah before you forget it or you
know mess it up or whatever yeah and I
think there are a lot of parallels
between that and product designers right
so just the idea or app developers or
startup founders right is that they have
this concept and not only do they have a
concept of a solution they actually are
envisioning a future for the world and
how their solution actually fits into
the way the world will work in the
future and so for me as well with music
man you know when I'm when I make a
record I'm making a record looking
towards timelessness right so when I
made that record with Cassie that record
still lives to this day we still get
sample request and clearance requests on
that record to this day as much as 13
years old right and so I always look at
that I always have an eye towards sort
of the timelessness and being timeless
means you have to have some sensibility
of what you believe the future will be
for sure so the music career is pretty
well-documented right with if you're a
Grammy nominated artist you can't hide
but you got this whole other side of
your life which is as a tech
entrepreneur an investor maybe tell us a
little bit about what you've been doing
on that side for for the last decade or
so yeah well I mean it's really related
so like I said we built a very huge
social following for Cassie and then all
of a sudden all those followers just
migrated away and I thought to myself
man you know we we invested so much to
to earn the equity in that social
platform and then it just disappeared as
people migrated off so we used to be
able to send a bulletin to 650,000
people and there was conversion and
there was you know there was engagement
and now because those people have
migrated to another platform we send a
bulletin and there's crickets and so I
thought to myself man it would have been
so much more prudent for me to collect
phone numbers because even though that's
a retro social handle it can be
retrofitted with modern technology and
so that's an experiment that I embarked
on in 2013 I gave my phone number out to
550,000 people on Twitter and man it
would it
was the birth of the platform which is
super fun today and so what I really
wanted to do was anyone who sent me a
text I wanted to know who they were
because obviously I didn't want to have
just a feed of unknown numbers so I
built a simple automation chain that
says look somebody sends a text you
don't recognize the number just hit that
person back say hey I don't recognize
this number I love to stay in touch
please add your information to my phone
second I was doing a lot of business on
Shopify so I wanted to check whether
they had purchased and in the event that
they still had yet to purchase send them
a recommendation to do so and then also
trigger at the time of purchase trigger
thank you and so that was a simple
automation chain step one two three
number one put your info in my phone
number two once I have your info check
and see if you've bought recommend that
you buy and then third thank folks and
man if the results of that sort of
experiment were staggering
thirty-five thousand of my five hundred
fifty thousand people actually texted me
every single one of them because of the
automation chain that was built received
a reply which said hey put your in for
my phone thirty-three thousand of the
thirty five thousand opted in by
entering their info on my phone and the
sales conversion was just literally just
unbelievable right fifty percent
seventeen thousand of the thirty three
thousand who received a link to purchase
actually bought and then I basically had
my most financially lucrative album
cycle run straight off the iPhone
straight off of text really and so I
knew at that juncture that I was on to
some future way of engaging an audience
and that led to an audience of one Ben
Horowitz who went on to be the first
investor in super phone and that really
was because Tristan Walker was an
entrepreneur in residence and in
Driessen at the time and set up the
meeting and man nurses from Atlanta to
Tristan is actually from out here over
Atlanta now based in Atlanta so he sold
his company Walker and company I was an
investor relations
yes sold it to Proctor and Gamble and
now he's in
Lana you know continue into you know
just keep it keep it hot down there it's
on the cover of Fast Company they did a
hole they did a hole you know special
article series of articles on Atlanta
Paul judge they featured he's also an
investor angel investor and superphone
so may I like that it is Lena yes so
super phone essentially you know when I
first saw it the first thing that jumps
to my mind is you're building a CRM tool
right absolutely which essentially
allows you to put people in they can
kind of self qualify themselves yes
right they can give you whatever
information they want yeah and then what
it allows you to do is know who they are
when you're communicating with them and
really break down the friction to
communicating with these people yeah and
over time it's really evolved into the
ability to set reminders you kind of all
these more what I consider like to two
hundred level or three hundred level
type actions but at the end of the day
we have CRN's or other tools from every
other communication platform yes male
social right also stuff text message is
still incredibly powerful and there was
nothing like this there was nothing like
it and trust me I had the money I could
have just paid for it the absence of a
solution even you know with the amount
that I was willing to pay and the
absence of that solution really created
the need and the necessity for me as an
innovator to bring this to life and man
listen I started out with giving my
phone number out to 550,000 people just
this summer Miley Cyrus gave her super
phone number out to 95 million Instagram
followers and listen the fun of building
a platform that you could watch to sit
back and scale and watching all those
phone calls come in and all those texts
go out and zero down down time and you
know high-fiving with the developers
that we could have done 10 of these
concurrently was just you know an
exhilarating feeling and so I think Ben
really was the first I mean I'd never
started a business or I mean outside of
a music business I wasn't a start-up
founder at all Ben was your entrepreneur
hold on the hook come on being a
musician or producer awesome right you
were an entrepreneur it might not have
been in a for-profit corporate
environment like a true startup way but
you're an entrepreneur yeah for sure and
I think
Ben really is an Oracle in that I mean
listen he's on the fours Midas list for
a reason and he basically said look Ryan
what I see in this and really our
exchange was pretty simple I just gave
him my phone number put my phone on the
table and said look send me a text and
I'll sell you my album I won't touch my
phone and it was paid what you want the
album was only twelve dollars and he you
know he paid $50 for it so I'm already
up in this meeting right and then he
went on to say look I love the I love
founders that solve their own problem
and you should really really consider
privatizing this because you have a deep
knowledge and sort of unique and the
moat around this business will be that
you are a founder who is building a
product that you have very very specific
knowledge on how to solve this challenge
and so man he was right you know he was
absolutely right and so yeah shout out
to Ben always for being the first to
invest that's awesome
all right we got to talk about Bitcoin
that's who you were early man you were
super early yes sir right what's the
first time you heard about Bitcoin I
heard about it really in like 2012 2011
and really might have just been just an
article I'd seen in passing I maybe read
some article about some engineers buying
pizza or something like that I thought
yeah that's funny and really didn't pay
much attention to it Ben actually was
the one that introduced me to Bryan
Armstrong and Fred who were the founders
of coinbase and I was sitting at one of
Ben's barbecues and Bryan you know says
look you know you should take this
seriously and just to get you on your
way out saying just a Bitcoin so he sent
me some big coin and coin base and there
I was you know with my first
cryptocurrency holding yeah and you're
up in that meeting as well now right we
got to figure out what this is you go to
meetings with people all sudden
you money over time that's right that's
right at the time I was like fine I was
with Bitcoin but I mean you know that's
definitely grown over time and so man
for me I'm always interested in really
any project or any interest that I have
I really throw myself into it right so
when I decided I wanted to do music or I
wanted to learn piano
I was practicing six seven hours a day
to the point where my little sister was
complaining to my parents hey Ryan's
hogging the piano not only is he hogging
the piano he's terrible at it right and
he's playing that thing for six seven
hours a day so when I really decided
like okay look you know I believe that
you know maybe it's the universe or some
cosmic whatever it is that's saying like
I should really pay attention to this
I said look let me try an experiment and
what's the best way for me to amass as
much of this cryptocurrency as possible
so one of the first forays was just
adding some way that people could
actually buy my digital album with
Bitcoin and so there was a plug in at
the time for Shopify so I did that and I
think if you look at the headlines even
50 cent you know I probably put him on
to that as well I mean I put a lot of
folks on to this Jeezy 50 you know
Nipsey Hussle the late great Nipsey
Hussle talk to them about cryptocurrency
so there was what's their reactions
right I mean these guys are Titans of
the music industry yeah even today right
yeah and you come to them you know hey
man there's this new currency right they
call Bitcoin yeah are they like a
variety whatever or is it like tell me
more about it and not think I think the
the real marker of any great
entrepreneur is the tolerance for risk
you know and so for me I and you know
it's actually a little crazy when you
think about the tolerance for risk is
that for me betting on myself I feel
like it's a very low-risk proposition
just because I believe that I'm built
for whatever I need to do to be
successful I'm built for whatever
critical and crucial elements are
necessary for me to be successful and
that's because I keep the promises I
make to myself that's how my confidence
has been built I make little promises to
myself I keep those promises I build
for instance so I believe that the real
marker of any great entrepreneur is the
fact that they have that kind of risk
tolerance and when they feel that gut
they bet on it and so for me when I
talked to those folks about it they
never really gave me the kind of
pushback of like I'm you know I'm not
interested in let's try this right and
maybe they just dip their toe in the
water right before jumping in I'm the
kind of person that really jumps in so
that my story can have some real
credence and gravitas and validation so
I can't just say you should try this
because I think it's cool you should try
this because I've actually gone through
the entire process I've learned and you
can learn from my learnings and actually
accelerate your ROI based on my
learnings right so that's why I try to
share as much as possible I believe that
my knowledge should create a runway so
other people can have ain't even more
explosive lift-off skirts want to know
who has the best URL crypto comm that's
right
crypto comm they're crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mine consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine comm tell
pomme Sencha and thank me later one more
word from our sponsor blocked by their
new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
you know the man I've never met a
successful person that doesn't believe
in betting on themselves yeah right I'm
at again you go any industry whether
it's business athlete musician whatever
the common theme across everyone is
listen I know it's gonna be hard I know
it might actually even be pretty close
to impossible yeah but it's me for sure
right if I bet on me
we'll see what happens but all the way
and I think part of it is actually and
what my partner's had talked to us
before it's not so much an arrogance of
hey I'm betting on me because I think
I'm better than everybody it's the exact
opposite actually
it's the I'm betting on me because if
this doesn't work I only want one person
to blame absolutely right and and it's I
don't want to count on somebody else to
be the person that something I'm doing
fails I want to be able to count on
myself
yeah the reason why we win or lose and I
think again you see you know the stories
of these athletes who get in the
Huddle's they give me the ball yeah you
know a player runner was playing run to
play give me the ball yeah yeah for sure
but sure and so I would say the biggest
bet that I met that I made was to
introduce Bitcoin or the concept of
Bitcoin to folks that were actually
paying me for my services so at the time
those services were you know what I was
doing host James we're doing concerts
etc I wanted all my advances to be paid
in Bitcoin and you just go to them and
just say hey I don't want dollars I want
Bitcoin yeah well yeah they say man I I
got screenshots on whatsapp but people
like what are you even talking about
like what is what what is this like you
know
you don't want dollars and so ya made it
so much easier yeah yeah yeah
and I mean I I was very very clear I
said look this is this is how I want to
get paid and so yeah I had a great deal
of shows and appearances and all kinds
of experiences for which I was paid at
Bitcoin um and it was a very significant
amount in in those early days and I've
just held since then yeah yeah that's
awesome
what why hold like what would just deep
conviction it is gonna be worth more the
future did you forget about it what was
kind of the thought process behind
holding yeah I think really uh first and
foremost I think just the culture of
what I've observed and sort of just
watching folks online that are excited
I mean it's wild man it's a combat zone
out there right right and you see it
every day they do it that they really
really believe yeah yeah and I mean
honestly you know there are definitely
opposing and polarizing viewpoints on
cryptocurrency and Bitcoin particularly
because it's the most prevalently sort
of widespread widely recognized currency
but I think really I think there are
there are a few indicators to me which
definitely gave me the confidence to
just hold on one of them was the
overstock deal right so the fact that
you can buy anything on an overstock
with Bitcoin and then also just the fact
that you know I'm really just fascinated
with just this concept of of value
exchange and value exchange that's trust
lists and I believe that you know beyond
just the concept of Bitcoin itself just
the fact that you can assign value based
on its its appearance on a ledger right
and that people are willing to exchange
goods and other currency for that I
think that you know at some point the
dust will settle and there will be some
value as long as people assign the value
to and I think we saw this pretty
rampantly in all of the icos that
that were happening right you know
everybody had a coin right oh and for me
I just kind of like watts from the
sidelines because I've I was holding
them you know the the the main you know
that crazy yeah the King right so for me
I think it's just about I'm just very
very curious about the about where it
will all pan out if you will and at
least for me as well and all of my other
investments I was early in Google Apple
Amazon Starbucks since 2007-2008
right and so and I just held right and
so I think that I I think that Warren
Buffett would disagree with me on
Bitcoin and he has I think very vocally
disagreed that there is any value there
but I think at the end of the day for me
value is what people assign and so to
the extent that there are P I mean
literally I had a phone call the other
day so I was like man I want to buy four
hundred thousand dollars with the
Bitcoin you know and they were looking
to say what exchange could I do this on
you know what I mean so yes you can't
say that it's worth zero yeah somebody's
willing to give four hundred thousand
dollars for some amount of them yeah
right and yes to your point it's there's
a marketplace right that marketplace
determines the price right now you can
argue that the price doesn't match the
ultimate value of the asset right but
you just can't argue with that yes
there's a price assigned to this as
being set by a marketplace that has
pretty good liquidity yeah and it is
what it is and when you think about you
know just the the the thesis behind
Bitcoin and just the fact that there is
a restricted volume of the currency
that's really where I think folks are
really looking at this as sort of a
stored value digital asset right and so
to the extent that Bitcoin eventually
you know and I've heard people talk
about this at various conventions and
conferences to the extent that it has
the scarcity associated with Bitcoin as
the same scarcity has been associated
with let's say gold for example then
really the price of a Bitcoin could
really you know right now it's hovering
at somewhere ten eleven thousand could
easily you know my price target was
always twenty five thousand right and
then you know there are folks who have
predicted that it could get to you know
100,000 of corn a million dollars a coin
should it actually reach the kind of
stored value assigned to it that gold
has a sign to it and so you know for me
I'm just I'm just watching man watching
I'm enjoying the I'm enjoying the the
gains that I've already realized and and
I'm just holding man you know you told
Jeezy you found a Bitcoin tell us that
story yeah I did so Ludacris was having
his birthday party 40th birthday party
Chateau in Paris and well out kind of
the outskirts of Paris and Jeezy and I
wanted to stay close to the city the
metropolitan city of lights Paris you
know shopping whatever it was you and
Jeezy going to the Eiffel Tower together
maybe you know the Cavalli store you
know because you know yeah one of the
freshest guys I know man snow you know
ice cold with it right so bottom line I
said look man you don't one of my
favorite restaurants is this this
Chinese restaurant called G up and so I
said look why don't we you know buy some
folks come and just chop it up have a
meal and literally for like an hour and
a half two sat down talked to him about
it showed him kind of the growth of my
holdings and just talk to him about just
having some diversity in his investment
portfolio that included you know what
some may consider a risky investment but
which has you know over time
I mean return to speak since I had a
beautiful return yeah yeah it's pretty
cool you get the opportunity to talk to
people who have so much influence right
yeah you've got the kind of your sphere
of influence and then the people that
you work with on a daily basis in the
music side same things you uh you've
been beating the beat the Bitcoin drum
for a while now yeah thank you all of us
yeah no no and just totally excited
about it man just totally excited about
and for me blockchain as well right so
blockchain is well I mean right now it's
super phone
the thesis for me is really about trust
and transparency and so you know it's
pretty polarizing right because when you
put this in a romantic context right how
many how many girls go through their
guy's phones right and how many are like
okay nothing's going on show me your
conversation with her you know show me
your DMS right and trust me I've had my
share right
and so with superphone what I'm what I'm
building and potentially there could be
a really beautiful blockchain component
to this is the fact that every message
could be stored on the blockchain and
eventually you'll be able to build a
relationship graph that tells you how
close you are to someone because every
message the interval between messages
every phone call the duration of phone
calls the interval between phone calls
that will all be logged on a blockchain
and then you know you don't have to
trust if you know hey this pump no ben
horowitz I'm looking for an intro will
just show me the relationship graph and
if everything is actually logged on this
ledger which is kind of applying the
blockchain to a data set which I think
is really really overlooked which is our
communication health right we already
have I would say services and apps which
track our health in terms of how many
steps we take or you know how many
calories we burned right to be able to
actually track that on a conversational
level I think is really gonna help to
accelerate success whether you're saying
that we're all salespeople in some way
right so if you're trying to get you
know this girl to go with you to the
prom then you you know or get this girl
to go on a date with you or whatever it
is you're selling at some point and so
the strength of relationships and the
ability I think to put some truth in
transparency to the point where you can
have a trustless system around how close
people are I think LinkedIn has tried to
up to this point do it I think it's
really powerful and also from a music
standpoint
Benji Rogers who's also an angel
investor in superphone started
PledgeMusic
and you know came up with this concept
this concept of dot blockchain where the
muse
filetype like mp3 or wav is very very
antiquated and so there's so much more
information that can be stored around my
latest recording and so once again that
also I think there are blocked in
applications for storing that data the
transfer of digital assets etc there's
so much there that's really exciting to
me around the blockchain for sure this
part of the automation series were doing
what's uh what's going on with
automation what he see in there was cut
you excited Oh for me am in so much so
much so alternating relationships very
polarizing very very polarizing topics
Oh super phone has a has a feature
called never lose touch and for me I
utilize that feature to make sure that
anytime whatever interval of time goes
by that I use the ball or drop the ball
with staying in touch with someone super
phone just jumps in and sends a message
now I've had some people that are just
like yo this is totally disingenuous if
you were really thinking about me then
you would actually open your phone
unlock it search for my name type of
text hit the send button because you're
really thinking about me sounds
inefficient right totally inefficient
and so I'll be honest with you you know
some of the most valuable relationships
in my life have been enriched by putting
this layer of automation that even
though I might get busy I might be in my
own world I might be working on music I
might be working on super phone it's
tracking these time lapses and it's
initiating conversations with me and the
people that really care to be in touch
with me they always respond and then
folks that are skeptical they've blocked
me they say look you know I don't even
want to be until you put a robot on me
and so I think yeah seriously yeah
seriously and so I think that uh that
maybe the robot King the robot King I
would say you know world's most
connected you know cuz when I meet
someone and they get into my super phone
I'm immediately tracking everything that
I just discussed so how long does it
take for pump to respond to me how often
do we have phone calls what's the
interval between phone calls does he
does he use emojis how much how many MMS
does he actually send does MMS actually
equate to you know
some larger event that's happening in
his life after an MMS does it
immediately upswing to a telephone call
so all of those data points are now in a
platform where you can't do this on how
message okay so now all these data
points are in a and in a platform that
makes that data actionable and so for me
automation is is key because of the
scale at which I'm texting I got 98
thousand text conversations in my super
phone I try to I try to do as little bot
work in there as as little as possible
right because that that communication
channel is so sacred is the most
important real estate that's in our
phones so the minister might feels like
a robot is in there they check out right
and so to the point that to the extent
that people understand that I'm building
and I'm testing I've had folks that have
built really beautiful relationships and
to be honest my relationship with my
mother has even improved just because I
know she's driving home from church on
Sundays so literally every Sunday at
1:30 her time Arizona a time that phone
call happens and it looks like my mom is
calling me doesn't matter what meeting
I'm in I say hey look I gotta take this
calls my mom just to check in and our
relationship has improved because of
that so listen maybe I'm living in the
future right and maybe in the future
everyone will just accept this as a
common practice but for right now it's
pretty polarizing I am automating those
portions and I'm autumn ating
conversation initiation as opposed to
conversation responses so this one I
guess part of this to ease some of the
sensitivities probably around text
messages are the highest signal
communication channel most of us have
right maybe I don't call it a little bit
higher but even with robo calls now
right I don't answer a single call if I
don't know the number yeah exactly and
so somebody text me I see it right and I
think that what you're getting at here
is you know this idea that if you
automate the initiation of the
conversation yeah really all it's doing
is basically serving as an alarm right
and it's saying hey you know you should
be talking to this person and
I think that there's this the study that
shows 150 people is kind of like your
circle yeah um buzz no yeah with
something like this right you're able to
actually expand that number yeah and
stay connected to a whole bunch more
people and again it's just you don't
actually have to communicate you know
groundbreaking ideas to people right
right just a simple hey thinking about
you yeah absolutely
have to go absolutely and also you know
I am interested in automating mundane
requests so if you were to text me right
now what's your email it's gonna hit you
what's best email for you it's just
gonna hit you right back yeah if you
were to text me right now hey where can
I get your latest music it'll hit you
right back because I believe that there
should be some value delivery of
convenience so if there is a data
repository that's just going to give you
the answer that you need immediately I
shouldn't have to actually you know I
mean I think it was Elon Musk who says
that we're limited by our thumbs the
speed of our thumbs right I'm gonna hit
you with a wild idea
let's go humans are actually inefficient
machines I agree right I agree and all
you're doing is you're taking one
machine yourself you're replacing it
with a more efficient more intelligent
machine absolutely absolutely right when
you look at it that way actually what
you're doing is you're improving my own
intent you're scaling my own intent
right and so man I'm running a lot of
businesses on superphone I'm running a
lot of businesses on Superfund whether
it's for my clients and customers or
whether it's for me so like right now
I'm running a an interactive wealth
building Club okay how's that was letter
it's called wealth plan and listen you
know there's a price point because I
need people to value what I'm offering
to them and it's really just runs I
already basically created the entire
brain trust it's 12 different lessons
it's delivered every month and over the
next year when you subscribe the wealth
plan you will get to follow my financial
moves mirror my financial moves a little
bit of crypto a little bit of real
estate investing it's not a solicitation
at all it's just a revelation of what
I'm doing to the extent that you'd like
to mirror it right
and so that is being done at scale over
superphone right and folks if they want
to text back because they have questions
I can differentiate in my text speed
who's actually a subscriber who's not
and I can give priority to the folks
that are actually members of this
interactive Club and so there are so
many applications for automation in like
I said I believe that the cell phone
number is our most powerful social
handle I think that Instagram has been
trying to definitely follow in that same
pathway by allowing folks to make phone
calls straight out of their DMS video
call straight out of their DMS as an
influencer so to speak with three
hundred and thirty thousand Instagram
followers that feature is not available
to me because they haven't built the
kind of management tools that wouldn't
be necessary for the amount of phone
calls and video calls that I would be
receiving so people can't call me I
can't call them with super phone though
all the management tools are built and
so only people that I want can ring
through only people that I want can
actually you know receive responses
organically from me but everyone else
that wants to be directly in touch with
me can do so so I think it's it's very
much in the same vein of what you're
talking about where I know the machine
that I would like to be and I've
attached technology to support that kind
of scaled intent that I'm looking to
deliver and part of this too I think is
we don't change our phone numbers that
much right so not only is it kind of the
most intimate social handle but but it
also is long-lasting almost every single
my friends so got the same number from
high school yeah yeah yeah first time
they got a cell phone right so so most
of your first I got on when they were
college men in high school they never
changed yeah and it becomes a part of
someone's identity right and so yeah I
mean listen I've always said this you
know when you get somebody on text
you're in touch with them as long as you
keep the conversation current until they
either block you changed their number or
died yeah you know you were making any
music so hey I'm always making music
yeah you know I really
went from doing like 150 shows a year to
just doing three four five shows a year
I'm really a full-time 50 shows per year
trust me when you love what you do it's
not even working listen we recorded a
150 podcast episodes in the last 12
months Wow exactly to the week Wow
and that was hard and all I had to do is
walk in this room and just talking this
microphone and leaving there's no
audience yeah why listen add the
audience add you know screaming girls in
the front row add wild after party or
like scrolls or that so that's about all
of it I'm telling you be a lot more
exciting a lot more fun lot more
exciting so that was trust me I I never
work never never for a moment felt like
it was work I was exhausted sometimes I
have doctors come give me a shot in my
bag all that kind of stuff but I had a
blast and now you know that that focus
that energy that passion that excitement
is is really 100% invested into super
fun I really believe that the work that
I'm doing and I'm seeing competitors
come out and clone what we're doing as
well and I think that's just validation
that the work that we're doing is
extremely valuable it's extremely
important and for first-movers just like
I was a first mover on YouTube the
arbitrage opportunity is now so you sign
up for super phone you have the ability
to be ahead of the curve in terms of
communication intimately at scale and
the kind of personalization that the
data from the context of a conversation
provides I mean it's very very powerful
for sure what uh we think the future
crypto is Bitcoin oh man where you think
we're headed man uh where are we headed
man like anything they you think a lot
about in the space or just more passive
hey I kind of made my my investment I'm
just gonna let it ride yeah no no I
think really for me I I think like I
said and we talked about it I think a
lot more about
blockchain and just the ability to have
that ledger and to have a trustless
system and I think a trustless system
that's that's yeah I think a trustless
system is is really just there's there's
a there's a there's an invaluable yeah
there's there's very there's there's a
it's very very tough to place a value on
how powerful a trustless system is right
I think that right now so much is
manipulated by motion so much is
manipulated by folks who have to give
the gab so much is manipulated by
headlines and so that trustless system
that gives the kind of truth and
transparency that allows us to make more
efficient decisions about where we want
to go in life that's really the the
piece about crypto and blockchain that
that excites me the most and I'm like I
said I'm looking to integrated
eventually into superphone as well yeah
I love it
before I finish up I let people ask me a
question but first we talked a Lian's
okay believer non-believer man I have
faith I have faith I think I have faith
I have faith yeah yeah I think they
exist and we just never came in contact
or you think that somehow somebody along
the way came in contact and area 51
almost crazy stuff is that I mean I had
to dig deeper know at the DOE papers a
big you know formulate my own opinion on
this I can't say that I've been wildly
entertained by Star Trek mm-hmm
growing up just because that's my mom
used to love to watch yeah and and so
like Ryan Leslie's never met aliens
before there are there have been some
people I have met that I'm like men you
know they're out of this world the other
world you know like some people say
jay-z Kanye all the aliens yeah listen
listen yeah true true so a question for
you man a question for you
where do you believe that crypto is
going well mr. fuse Allah give me give
me more of a shorter a nearer term yeah
look look I have two core thesis right
this kind of short medium and long term
which is just Bitcoin is real because
it's people gonna trust algorithms to
store their wealth right just like you
trust algorithms with Google Maps for
directions or music recommendations all
this stuff right so it makes sense to me
that eventually it'll permeate into our
financial lives yeah
and the other is that every stock bond
currency and commodity eventually gets
digitized right yeah now in the short
term I'm really really paying attention
to a lot of these currency wars that are
playing out and kind of more like global
macro stuff and the thought process
there is just we're literally seeing the
perfect movie script play out for why
bitcoin is important yeah right you know
you forget all the politics of whether
you like the president you don't like
the president whatever when they're
tweeting about how monetary policy
should be implemented and you know we're
gonna have a trade war and this person
or that person also but she Rises bunch
of chaos yeah right and so you may like
the chaos you may not like the cast it
don't really matter it's hard to argue
there's not chaos yeah and I really like
it's a Chum off the social capital says
you know bitcoins just like schmuck
insurance right over kind of chaos hedge
yeah and so the more chaotic the world
gets there's some people who just say I
want some percentage of my wealth to be
stored somewhere that super transparent
that's trustless that doesn't have the
chaos right and again I don't think
that's gonna be a hundred percent of
every single person on the planets
wealth yeah especially on the short-term
but I think that kind of paradigm
comparison between the chaotic world and
the non chaotic world to me is just it's
fascinating right and it's something
that previously wasn't really available
to people now it's here it seems to be
working it seems to be getting adopted
and yeah I I've now shifted to I don't
try to convince people that it's real
right here's what I say to them how sure
or how confident are you that is not
gonna work yeah you a hundred percent
confident mmm-hmm because
you're just 99% confident posh you get
1% right you you know you should line up
how you think about your wealth and your
assets with your confidence level yeah
right for sure and so if you want to be
a hundred percent committed to the Fiat
kind of traditional legacy world and
you're a hundred percent confident that
this other stuff is not gonna work
go ahead that's fine it really you know
few and far between the people who think
that they're a hundred percent confident
and so it leads to you know kind of
these bigger conversations that I think
are more important yeah and I will say
this as well I'm I'm all about speed and
efficiency and I'll just I'll just be
real what's important to me is speed and
efficiency so let's give you a case in
point went to the bank I wanted to you
know give some my twenty thousand
dollars right they don't have the same
Bank as me so I go to the teller I say
look you know I want to you know I want
to give some my twenty thousand dollars
what's the easiest way to do it they say
okay well there's two ways you can do a
cashier's check or you could try to do a
wire but it's after 5:00 p.m. so you
know it's after 4:30 the other bank is
open but we can't guarantee the wire
still goes out today I'm just like man
that's my bread and I should be able to
move it instantly if I wanted to let me
be real with you literally two different
financial institutions I did a cashier's
check and because it was after 4:30 they
were like look it's not gonna clear the
same day it was a Friday it wasn't even
clear till Monday I went back to the
other financial institution took out 20
bands in cash went to the other
financial institution they said hey look
you know it's too much money you can't
deposit to somebody else's account so I
had to go and put the cash back in my
account and I'm just like look to the
extent that you were just talking about
the kind of efficiency look look how
much time I just wasted and because I
care about that person I did everything
that I could do to make that happen
but at the size of that transaction you
know twenty thousand dollars the rings
and hoops that I had to jump through in
AML questionnaires and passports etc
like I'm just about efficacy man I
worked for that money I should be able
to redistribute it as instantly as you
know the IRS will come in and seize it
you know
you store your money in a place that's
closed more hours a week than it is open
yeah right pretty crazy to think about
that you know when you need it you may
or may not be able to access it yeah
yeah all right listen you've been
killing the game for a long time I
appreciate you coming in it sure about
all this stuff and yeah hopefully people
will start to kind of be warmed up to
the idea of how long you've been in
Bitcoin hey and you're one of the
leaders there so so thank you from all
of us for for pushing that narrative
with a lot of people with a lot of
influence for sure and anybody that you
know has unanswered questions wants to
reach me directly I have a URL you can
leave your number I'll text you right
back it's texts Ryan calm very simple
just visit that on your mobile browser
leave your number I don't have to give
you my number you just have to know
yours you drop it in there I'll text you
right back in so yeah just hit me text
Ryan comm text Ryan comi it's super easy
super easy number I text you back thanks
mom
all right thank you appreciate you hey
everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain home page scroll down
until you see the five blank stars
taking 15 seconds to fill those stars in
and leave a quick review goes a long way
in helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain